good afternoon everyone thank you for
joining us today and over the past few
days this afternoon rear Admiral John
mauger will be providing an update on
the most recent findings from ROV
operations in search of the Titan
submersible he will provide a brief
statement and provide the opportunity
for questions after please limit your
questions to one per Outlet
following the briefing the joint
information center staff and I will be
here to help you with any of your
further needs may I now please introduce
rear Admiral John mauger
this morning
an ROV or remote operated vehicle from
The Vessel Horizon Arctic discovered the
tail cone of the Titan submersible
approximately 1600 feet
from the bow of the Titanic on the sea
floor
the ROV subsequently
found additional debris
in consultation with experts from within
the unified command
the debris is consistent with the
catastrophic loss
of the pressure chamber
upon this determination we immediately
notified the families
on behalf of the United States Coast
Guard and the entire unified command
I offer my deepest condolences to the
families
I Can Only Imagine
what this has been like for them
and I hope that this discovery
provides
some soulless during this difficult time
additionally we've been in close contact
with the British and French consuls
General
to ensure that they are fully apprised
and that their concerns are being
addressed
the outpouring of support in this highly
complex search operation has been robust
and immensely appreciated
we are grateful for the rapid
mobilization of experts on the undersea
search and rescue and we thank all of
the agencies and personnel
for their role in the response
we're also incredibly grateful for the
full spectrum of international
assistance that's been provided
the rovs will remain on scene and
continue to gather information
again
our most heartfelt condolences
go out to the loved ones of the crew
we'll now take questions
we talk about the delay in
this was a incredibly complex case
and we're still working to develop the
details for the timeline involved with
this casualty and the response James
flown what other debris have you found
and have you found any trace of those
who were on
so this is an incredibly complex uh
operating environment on the sea floor
over two miles beneath the surface and
so uh the the remote operating vehicle
has been searching and it is highly
capable and we've been able to classify
uh parts of the pressure chamber for the
Titan submersible let me refer to one of
my undersea experts here Mr Paul hankin
to talk about the nature of some of the
debris
thank you Admiral
so essentially we found uh five
different major pieces of of debris that
uh
told us that it was the
remains of the Titan the initial thing
we found was the nose cone which was
outside of the pressure Hall
we then found a large debris field
within that large debris field
uh we found
the the front end Bell of the pressure
hole
that was the first indication that
um
there was a catastrophic event
shortly thereafter we found the
a second smaller debris field within
that debris field we found
the the other end of the pressure Hall
the AFT and Bell
um
which was basically the comprised that
the totality of that pressure vessel we
continue to map the debris field and as
the Admiral said we will
do the best we can to
fully map out what's down there
so so the questions was uh related I'm
restating the question from the
standpoint of uh sometimes it's hard to
hear the question here what are the
prospects for re uh recovering crew
members and so uh this is a incredibly
unforgiving uh environment down there uh
on the sea floor uh and uh the debris is
consistent with a catastrophic uh
implosion of the vessel and so uh we'll
continue to work and continue to search
the area uh down there but uh I I don't
have an answer for prospects at this
time emeralds Tom Costello at NBC News
is there any suggestion
sorry any suggestion at all that the
that the sub itself collided with the
wreckage of Titanic or that instead it
might have imploded above the wreckage
and then rained down nearby
so the question was is there any
question as to whether or not the sub
collided with the Titanic or whether it
imploded uh above and debris uh field
created from that uh so the uh the the
location of the Titan submersible was in
an area that was approximately 1600 feet
from uh the wreck of the Titanic uh I
have an expert here that can that is
familiar with that area and can talk
about uh the debris field and and what
uh the debris field indicates in terms
of uh the where the casualty may have
occurred
wait let's get
the X please hang on a second the expert
Voice is coming up to answer the
question uh
Admiral so the question is where does
the wreck lie in relation to the Titanic
uh I didn't hear the Admiral's uh answer
I think 1600 feet was that correct uh so
that's uh that's off the bow of Titanic
it's in an area where there is not any
debris of Titanic it is a smooth bottom
uh there to my knowledge and anything
I've seen there's no Titanic wreckage in
that area and again 200 plus meters from
the bow uh inconsistent with the
location of last communication for an
implosion in the water column and the
size of the debris field is consistent
with that implosion in the water column
you say that this was a catastrophic
imposing and I know it's early on but is
it your estimation that this happened
right at the moment when they lost
contact an hour
five minutes after they're sent from uh
so the question was about the timing of
the catastrophic implosion uh right now
it is uh too early to tell with that we
know that as we've been Prosecuting uh
this search over the course of the last
uh 72 hours uh and and beyond that we've
had sonar buoys in the water nearly
continuously and have not detected any
catastrophic events uh when those sonar
buoys have been in the water so
in the next days
so we will uh the question was uh what
happens from here uh what What's the
next phase
um and so right now again our thoughts
are with the families uh and making sure
that they have uh
um an understanding as best as we can
provide
of of uh what happened and and uh begin
to find some closure uh in terms of the
large process we're going to continue to
uh
investigate the site of the debris field
uh and then I know that there's also a
lot of questions about uh how why and
when uh did this happen
um and so uh you know those are
questions that uh we will collect as
much information as we can on uh now uh
while uh the governments are are meeting
and And discussing uh you know what uh
an investigation of this nature of a
casualty might look like this is
something that happened I'll just just
remind everybody this is something that
happened in a remote portion of the of
the ocean uh with uh people from you
know several different countries around
the world uh and so it is a complex case
to work through but I I'm confident that
those questions will be begin to get
answered well the Coast Guard lead the
investigation sir
the the question was uh was there any
suggestion that time factors uh may have
uh played a a
role or or a consideration in uh the the
casualty here and so the debris field is
consistent with a catastrophic uh
implosion of the vessel again while we
were Prosecuting the search we had
listening devices in the water
throughout and did not hear any signs of
catastrophic failure from those and so
we're going to continue to investigate
uh or we're going to continue to
document the information there and and
understand based on all the information
we have the the timeline
so the question was what uh what are the
resources required for the investigation
and which ships will be pulling out and
uh staying in and so uh it it's too
early for me to talk about an
investigation that's a decision that's
going to be taken outside of uh the
search and and uh efforts that I was
leading uh and but we do have a number
of vessels we have nine vessels on the
scene right now we had medical uh
Personnel on team we had other
technicians on scene and so we will
begin to demobilize uh personnel and and
vessels from the scene uh over the
course of the next uh 24 hours but we're
going to continue uh remote operations
on the sea floor uh and and I don't have
a timeline for when we would intend to
stop remote operations on the sea floor
at this point
in the way
safety rated or inspected so that this
won't happen again yeah the question was
essentially about do you think that
there should be changes in safety
ratings or inspection for these
standards I
I know that there's a lot of questions
about why how when this happened and and
the members of the unified command you
know have those questions too as as
professionals and experts that work in
this environment and this is an an
incredibly difficult and dangerous
environment to work in out there but
those those questions about
the regulations that apply and and the
standards that's going to be I'm sure
focus of future review right now we're
focused on documenting uh the the scene
and continuing the the support
directed
employed the rovs to this area is there
anything conclusive in those noises and
did that redirection and then finding
this debris field today
all help
so uh throughout the search efforts we
reacted to the information that we had
available to us
and while we continue to send it off for
deeper analysis again really complex
operating environment for us to work in
uh
let me check with the experts but there
doesn't appear to be any uh connection
between the noises and
the location on the sea floor again this
was a catastrophic implosion of the
vessel which would have generated a
significant Broadband sound uh down
there that the Sono buoys would have
picked up well a lot of questions about
who might be you mentioned closer for
the family
can I just ask you about your your
comment regarding the families
this was a uh incredibly uh complex
operation uh and uh we were able to
mobilize an immense amount of gear uh to
the site and uh just a really remarkable
amount of time given the fact that we
started without any sort of vessel
response plan for this or any sort of
pre-stage resources and so the equipment
that was brought on site this morning
that we were using was a pelagic ROV
capable of operating at 6 000 meters
cameras sonar other articulating arms
and and resources on it and it's uh you
know we had to transport it here through
C-17 aircraft this is two aircraft that
it took to get this up here and so we've
really had the the right gear on site
and worked as uh as as swiftly as
possible to bring all of the
capabilities that we had to Bear uh to
this search and rescue effort uh and it
was just a huge uh International and
interagency effort to make this happen
uh so I'm I'm really grateful for all of
uh the responders that came out to
support this uh and and really uh you
know search uh for uh for the vessel it
is a difficult day for all of us
um and and it's especially difficult uh
for the families and our thoughts are
with the families uh today but this was
an immense uh support and we had the
right gear on the bottom uh to to find
it Well you mentioned
will you attempt to recover the bodies
can we ask you though the victims will
they be recovered thank you so much
everyone for attending this afternoon
there are no future planned press
conferences